good morning Hank it's Monday Hank it's
no secret that the three most viewed
videos on the vlogbrothers channel
feature in order giraffe sex giraffe sex
and giraffe sex and yet Hank it recently
occurred to me that in spite of all of
this we have never actually made a video
about giraffe sex a shortcoming I intend
to rectify today so Hank not to call you
up but the other day on Twitter you
tweeted an image that you designed now
hey let's put aside the question of why
you a busy professional spend your free
time coming up with cute images of
giraffe love this would make a great
t-shirt and so it is a great t-shirt hey
nerdfighters that shirt is available for
pre-order now at dftba.com link in the
doobly-doo
but anyway make your illustration of
giraffe love maybe adorable but it
completely belies the truth about
giraffe mating which is that it is
profoundly non romantic to begin with
Hank giraffes are extremely promiscuous
and when I say extremely promiscuous I
mean they rarely mate with the same
person twice in fact they don't mate
with people at all they mate with
giraffes although that reminds me of a
yahoo answers question that I wanted to
read to you are male giraffes gay
homosexual I heard that they were and if
they are would they be interested in
male humans my friend was asking and I
said I would find out for him
Hank pardon me for a moment I need to
use the desk really quickly Oh desk Oh
internet what disturbing question won't
you ask well Hank to answer that
question on behalf of someone's
non-existent friend almost all male
giraffes are bisexual in fact
researchers believe that ninety percent
of total giraffe sex is male giraffes
having sex with male giraffes and that
1% of total giraffe sex is females
having sex with females meaning that
just about 9% of giraffe sex is
heterosexual and that's really no wonder
Hank because their heterosexual sex is
do you like a mom so Hank I present to
you the majestic giraffe stop looking at
me that way I know your secrets giraffe
mating involves a process called flamin
or possibly Fleming I don't know how to
pronounce it and I don't want to learn
basically male giraffes don't really
like hooking up with female giraffes
unless they're ovulating so to find out
if their obviating they use their faces
to smack the female giraffes in the
bottom which causes the female giraffes
to pee if they happen to like
the male giraffe they'll pee a bunch and
then the male giraffe drinks the pee to
find out if it tastes like it's time to
party hey I will remind you I am NOT
that perfect here I am just reporting
the facts he's the perfect
then if the pee smells right and the
lady's still into it there's a courtship
process which mostly involves the male
giraffe trying to hump the female
giraffe and the female giraffe running
away until finally coitus occurs lasting
up to several seconds then the mommy
giraffes are pregnant for 400 freaking
days no wonder they try to run away and
the male giraffe just goes on his merry
way hooking up with dudes and smacking
pee out of girls I wish I were making
this up so anyway Hank the long and
short of it is that the animal kingdom
is rarely as romantic as we'd like it to
be but there's one super cute thing
about giraffes as seen in your image
they neck a lot and for a long time
biologists thought this was a way of
fighting but it turns out that while it
is sometimes a way of fighting it's also
kind of a way of hugging so the shirt
isn't a lie it's just an
oversimplification like someday when
Henry asks me how is it that baby
giraffes come into the world I will put
on the shirt and I will say Henry this
shirt was designed by your uncle Hank to
answer that very question as this
helpful diagram shows when giraffe's
neck there is a heart that forms in the
space between their necks and that heart
thus ends our introduction to giraffe
mating habits there's a link to Hanks
t-shirt in the doobly-doo Hank thank you
for designing that I always forget that
you're so talented
I know that sounds stupid but every time
I see something you've designed I always
think wow it is pretty you know good at
stuff that's about as close as brothers
get to complementing each other Hank
I'll see you on Wednesday